other side it requires a policy change
on our side as well we just have to find
the right equilibrium to make sure that
as they change we change because
otherwise we're not going to live in a
world in which we can just wish for
others to change their behavior but we
ourselves are completely flawless just
had a couple questions with respect to
we understand how Israel was against the
deal well we understand how Israel was
against the deal but can you elaborate
on what Saudi Arabia was doing behind
the scenes to try to thwart the deal and
then I have a second question with
respect to Qatar
where does Iran figure into this
constant barrage of art of news rather
advertisements on TV against against
Qatar thank you so much on the first
question I want to also emphasize yes
Netanyahu was against and the political
establishment was against the security
establishment in Israel many key
individuals were very much in favor of
this deal and they continued to speak
out in favor of this deal because they
believe ultimately this was good for
Israel Netanyahu is obviously different
when it comes to this the Saudis had a
much less visible role when it comes to
their opposition they were making their
opposition very clear to the
administration but unlike the Israelis
who would come in and they would say we
want you to have far less centrifuge you
should push harder on this issue etc the
Saudis had no opinions on the number of
centrifugal because they don't have a
nuclear program so they wouldn't really
be able to have the technical expertise
their problem was in some ways more
honest and direct how can you make a
deal with this government in Iran in a
very naked way saying they don't want to
see any deal whatsoever at all I would
say that the Saudi opposition to the
deal has become much more visible and
perhaps intensified after the deal than
what it was before Netanyahu was taking
the lead prior to the deal there are
certain moments in which at least the
Iranians are convinced that the Saudis
intervened in November 2014 there was a
final negotiation they had a deadline
they had not extended it and they
thought that they couldn't extend it the
Iranian narrative is that the
essentially came very close to a deal
the Iranian Foreign Minister said that
he was even discussing a press release
with the German Foreign Minister and
then Kerry took a break he went to
Vienna Airport he met in the private
airplane of the Saudi foreign minister
at the time he came back and the
Iranians say that after that was just a
complete sea change and he was back down
on what he had said earlier on the
American narrative is very different
they don't believe that there was they
were close to an agreement to begin with
and as one of the US negotiators said
the Iranians looked at what happened
they looked at the meeting with the
Saudi foreign minister it took two plus
two and they made five out of it so
there's some you know diverging
narratives as to whether the Saudis
played a role or not but in retrospect
the Iranians are convinced that what
happened that day was because the Saudis
intervened they don't know exactly what
happened but that's their conclusion
regards to Qatar I've been out of the
country for the last couple of weeks one
of the great joys of not being in the
United States is I don't see any
political ads on the TVs in Europe so I
have no idea what you're talking about
when it comes to Qatar I've heard about
them but I've not seen this I can't
comment thank you
I would just like to ask you to comment
further on the internal repercussions
within Iran if if Trump decides to so if
if Trump walks away from the tournament
and you can feel free to differentiate
between the repercussions according to
different ways of walking away thank you
so one thing I think is important to
understand if the u.s. walks out of this
deal is what this would do for any
future opportunities to be able to get
any negotiations going between the
United States and Iran the hardliners in
Iran are on the record
consistently regardless of what the
United States is doing saying you cannot
trust the u.s. even the supreme leader
said well I'm supporting the negotiators
but he said ultimately I think we have
to be very careful because you can't
trust the u.s. well it would be really
sad if Trump does anything that would
give the supreme leader the vindication
of being able to say that he was right
and part of the reason for that beyond
the immediate effects of the deal
collapsing and potentially putting war
with Iran and Eve on a nuclear weapon
back on the table is the next time there
is a need to dissolve something
diplomatically those within Iran's elite
the foreign policy elite how will they
make the argument that yes we should go
back to the negotiating table because we
can't strike a deal and the US will live
up to it just as much as we would have
tremendous difficulty on this side if
the Iranians did cheat if they broke
away from the deal can you imagine how
difficult it would be for the next Obama
to be able to make the argument we have
to pursue negotiations instead of
pursuing the path of George Bush this is
really what's at stake it's not just
about this deal it's about the future
being able to resolve things
diplomatically but let me also say
something about internal politics in
Iran I think is very important it's
connected to what the previous gentleman
asked about changes I think there's been
changes internally in Iran we've seen
some of them small but very important
but they have not really been reported
in the United States so we may be
forgiven for having missed them you all
heard that there were elections in Iran
again these are not free and fair
elections but they're far more
competitive than almost any other
elections in the Middle East
certainly more competitive than the non
existing elections in Saudi Arabia but
what most people probably did not hear
about is that in the city council level
in which the elections are actually more
fear than they are at the presidential
level the reformist swept almost
everything in all the major cities they
took all of the seats in the very
conservative city of Mashhad a woman ran
for the City Council the City Council
are pretty important even on the
platform of opposing the patriarchy her
slogan was elect more women she won the
number of women who won in the last
elections I believe tripled or
quadrupled these are internal changes
that are taking place that will speed up
if there is peace between the United
States and Iran and in the region as a
whole and they will certainly be
trampled and and and undermined if we
have more external tensions so if we
want to see that type of a change in
their context in the foreign policy it
will ultimately have to come because
Iran is also changing internally if we
want to change internally rest assure
threats of war sanctions and threats of
regime change is not helping the Iranian
people drive things in a democratic
direction thank you so much
[Applause]
of losing an enemy are available at the
checkout desk treati will be up here
signing formal line to the right of the
table and please fold up your chairs
book TV recently visited Capitol Hill to
ask members of Congress what they're
reading this summer I let me back into
that question by saying I highly and
strongly encourage people to read
whether they be young whether they be
old it opens up vistas at expand your
horizon you learn and gain knowledge and
it just inspires you in lots and lots of
ways so you don't have to necessarily
for instance go on a long trip to feel
like you've been there if you read about
the place in the book and look at the
photographs and things like that I was
going to point out a couple of books
that I've read in the past first you've
got behind me these are some autographs
that I've collected over the years on
the very top you've got Winston
Churchill and it just so happens the
first autobiography I ever read was a
book by Winston Churchill called my
early life and that got me interested in
reading biographies and autobiographies
and plus I love Winston Churchill's way
of writing grey uses a lot of transitive
verbs that's very expressive is very
memorable so I've tried to emulate
Winston Churchill without much success
because I think he's such a great writer
you have Abraham Lincoln's autograph
here this is a Lincoln member of
Congress this is a copy of a photo that
I got from the Library of Congress
that's the copy of the only photograph
of Lincoln when he was in college but it
so happens he's one of my favorite
presidents and I've read just about
every biography I can think of of
Lincoln one of the best is by Benjamin P
Thomas as a one-volume biography of
Lincoln and it won the Pulitzer Prize
some years ago so that might be a
recommendation there on the bottom is an
autograph
James Madison that's there just to
remind me that we're all here to he's
known as the father the Constitution
there were all in Congress too just to
you know basically guard and protect and
enforce the Constitution and I've read
biographies of James Madison as well and
he's not as well known as other
presidents but again one of those early
dedicated individuals who helped build
our country start the foundation of our
government and there really is a is a
great president and lots and lots of
ways but now to get to your the answer
to your question what if I read recently
so happens that just yesterday morning I
finished a book called the gatekeepers
and it's a book about the Chiefs of
Staff of presidents and it is this book
right here by Chris Whipple
interestingly enough and I hope he won't
take this personally I think he might
have benefited a little bit by having
his own chief of staff this is a very
good book I think it could have been
maybe slightly better if he had had a
chief of staff himself who said maybe
better not to put in these half-dozen
paragraphs still a great book I'm just
saying that maybe there were a
half-a-dozen progressí might have
thought about taking out and but it was
still still worth reading and I'm doing
book notes on this and that brings up
another subject my staff is nice enough
to type up whenever I read a book they
type up everything that I've underlined
and I underline every book I have this
would be an example of book notes from
and this is from a book called the
agenda mover it was a book I read before
the gatekeepers and this was just
wonderful I'd recommend this to any
member of Congress because it the
subtitle is when your good idea is not
enough you really it's not enough just
to come up with a good idea you have to
figure out a way to build coalitions to
actually put it into into practice or
put it into effect or enacted in the
case of legislation so the agenda mover
I just thought was one of the best books
I've read if anybody wants book notes
I'll be happy to share my Reader's
Digest version on that a couple other
books there was one on climate there was
one on leadership and I'll show you
these right here this was a book unusual
says rare leadership it was also a rare
book on leadership there was a little
bit of the spiritual dimension to the
and about you know increasing trust and
joy and engagement in the people you
lead so was it a it wasn't a hard-boiled
kind of leadership it was a leadership
that was more emotional more intuitive
and more of uplifting than some other
books on leadership this is a book by
Roger pinky he's somebody who's
testified before the science committee
that I chair called the climate fix it's
not a he is not a climate denier nor am
i but this is a down the down the middle
of the road book on climate change and
making the point that I happen to agree
with that better than government
mandates better than high taxes why
don't we let technology solve our
problems why don't we need let
innovations reduce our carbon emissions
that's been the way it has been with the
United States and with America
throughout our history technology has
solved our communication problems it
solved our healthcare problems that
solved our transportation problems why
shouldn't it solve our energy issues as
well so that's why that's why I as
chairman of the Science Committee of
trying to put more money into R&D
research and development for climate
change oh this is the next book I hope
to read is called do I make myself clear
despite and what some people are saying
in the office this was not given to me
by my wife but it's about how to write
better and I tried to improve my writing
unfortunately I'd never stopped editing
to the consternation and frustration of
many of my staff but as long as they
give it back to me I'm going to keep
editing whatever I've written whether it
be an op-ed piece or a statement that I
might be giving you know in the hearing
or markup of legislation but they're
just a wealth of wonderful books out
there and I'm frustrated because I can't
read everything that I'd like to read I
try to read a book every week or two and
I didn't really learn to love to read
till college but it just is I found it
very very helpful now either you get
good ideas it helps to inspire you it
helps you I think be a better person a
lot of ways to having said that my
caveat would be that I think you can
read too much and I think I'm getting to
that point where I'm not just reading to
read but I mean I'm I'm loving what I
read
I picked subjects that I want to read
about mostly they're nonfiction
sometimes they're on leadership and
whatnot but I think it's important and
just as important to stop and think as
it is to read you can think about what
you've read you can think about life you
can think about how to do your job
better you can think about how to help
more people so I'd say it's important
not just to try to read to read but it's
important to read for a purpose and I
think it's important after you read take
some time to think about what you've
just read or as I say life in general
and maybe that'll change your reading
habits maybe you'll think about reading
on a different subject as a result of
just thinking but so I'd say I'm a
proponent today for reading but also
reading and thinking that accommodation
I think is a potent one how does taking
notes while you read really display that
really does she'll really show how you
think and read well I like to underline
points that are important in a book that
I am reading for a couple of reasons one
if I underline them
I remember them better and I've been
I've read them twice or even three times
because I read them once and then I go
back and and underline a passage that I
particularly liked or found salient and
so I think that is helpful to me and
then who knows that the poor intern in
my office who gets to type up on my book
notes I hope he or she is learning
something as well they tell me they are
in that way they sort of get to feel
like they read the book even though
they're just typing up my book notes and
then I give those footnotes to my family
members I give them to senior staff on
the committee and in the personal office
as well I'm not convinced that they read
all my book notes but I think they read
some of the book notes and and found
them helpful but that's what I do do i I
underlined or ticking the margins
passages that I think are important book
TV wants to know what you're reading
send us your summer reading list via
twitter at book TV or instagram at book
underscore TV or post it to our Facebook
page facebook.com slash book TV book TV
on c-span - television for serious
readers
Shelby Steele your most recent book
called shame where did that title come
from well I wrestled with the title for
a long time on on this book yeah there
are many different themes I entered to
try to introduce him in the book and I
couldn't find that sort of single thing
finally I came upon with my wife's help
the word shame and that that word seemed
to bring together all the themes that I
was trying to work with in the book so
that's that central theme you were going
for it is the idea is that America
arguably the greatest country in all of
history also committed one of the
greatest sins perpetrated that sin over
centuries dehumanized an entire race of
people relentlessly year in and year out
for a very long time so it's a profound
evil in amidst stunning greatness and so
now that that greatness I think of
course is what finally delivered us from
from what we were doing wrong but on the
other hand it it is a shame that we will
now have to deal with and so it's a it
is maybe we're still too close to the
sixties when we first acknowledge this
shame to understand its importance but I
think it's one of the most important
events in all of them American history
certainly
how does a society that believes and
freedom grounded in freedom
deal with having betrayed it and so the
book sort of tries to look at different
aspects of that that irony and in my
reading of it the shame belongs to the
1960s liberal movement in your view and
it's that's what's caused our current
political polarization yes thank you
that's that's a fair assessment in in
the 1960s American liberalism changed
and took responsibility for dealing with
that shame and and saying in effect we
are the politics the ideology that is
going to redeem America's going to bring
back American legitimacy as a democracy
that's our mission
and if liberalism has I think dominated
American politics for the last 50 60
years simply because it took propriety
over this terrible shame and said we
will save America from it and we will
end racism and we will end sexism and we
will overcome all of those things and we
will the people we hurt we will have
great societies and wars on poverty and
we will will redeem them and bring them
up to par with everyone else will
correct that and that will really
restore our legitimacy as a free society
and in your book the n-word is used
pretty liberally uh-huh and yes you say
that some people some groups co-opted it
they didn't necessarily want to be but
they co-opted the word yes
what were their own political purposes
yes yeah well it took it over and almost
made a romance around it and sort of
ascribed to that word a kind of kind of
power and and a truth that had never
been there really before but did serve
their their argument there because much
of the argument certainly coming from
minorities in America as for the last 50
years since the sixties has been now you
have to America now you have admitted
all that you did and we are we we now
demand in the name of what we suffered
that that empowers us that gives us an
entitlement to special consideration in
American life now
and so that word was was was just a part
of a theme that contributed to that
larger point of view its power and
victimization
why did you include the story of your
swim team and quitting the swim team in
this book I included that story talking
about quitting the swimming team and and
this story that I was the only black kid
on the swimming team and the question
that was the captain of the team and the
coach and I were very close really but
in the summer before my senior year he
had a three-week sort of summer vacation
for the entire team at his mother's home
in Upper Lake Michigan and he never
invited me and I was I was excluded him
and not meanly in any way but I just
that the team organized around without
me knowing anything about it this
wonderful time they were going to have
in the lake and I was never told about
it well
the implication there is that he
collaborated with racism he was my
friend he was a good coach we were we
liked each other but he he wasn't going
going his mother said no blacks can can
can come and so he honored that and he
he plotted with the parents of others
the other swimmers and so forth so that
did not happen he was a metaphor in that
sense for America he knew better he
liked me I liked him
I babysat for him and yet he
collaborated in a way that was that was
certainly at the very least cruel but
sending me a message
that larger America said there was
something unacceptable about me and he
he he claimed he was not able to see
that but I think he was and so I I talk
about him and this is the situation of
this sort of profound hypocrisy then
America is now in America is now looking
at minorities as my swimming coach
looked at me and he called me over he
got mad he called me every name in the
book and he said I was a militant there
that was all of this I was very calm
because I knew he was wrong and he knew
he was wrong and America now stands
before its minorities humble apologetic
begging for some relief from the stigma
of racism and and that is minority power
that is the power minorities have
wielded in American life now for 50
years
and so that little incident of the of
putting the swimming team and I did not
quit the swimming team because of what
he excluded me I grew up in segregation
I'd seen it all the time I was you know
I've been here all day talking about all
the incidents of segregation I enjoyed
so but I knew that he was he was
compromised and so that's what that's
what in the sense it ended up a mounting
to what was your parents life like in
1940 Chicago
my parents are two very exceptional
people I'm actually writing about them
in the future
they were my father was black from the
South third grade education taught
himself to read and write
my mother was upper middle class white
from Ohio the daughter of a contractor
and a master's degree from University of
Chicago and and so forth so they were
very on the surface they were very
different you you know once you got to
know them you saw that probably was my
father who was better read and spent
more time reading and and than my mother
but they they had for them life was they
were exceptional people in that they
knew from and had no illusions about the
fact that they were going to have to
fight for a place in American life and
they did it they and they did it without
ever complaining without any compunction
they were founding members of core
Congress of racial equality they I grew
up as what they call a core baby red
diaper babies and then they had core
babies that was the core baby so I
marched all through childhood and and
demonstrated and that was the ethos that
that I came out of and they lived their
entire lives fighting for civil rights
and
they were they were true there were two
admirable people were they wrong were
they were they wrong they were not wrong
they were right and this is a points to
something I think it's important they
were not wrong in their day this was a
deeply blanketly racist society I grew
up I couldn't go here I couldn't go
there I we we never ate in a restaurant
until I was 17 on the swimming team
because you blacks couldn't go in
restaurants you couldn't get a job there
you you know segregation was everywhere
they were fighting a real concrete
unapologetic enemy in America in
American society that said listen you're
going to stay inferior you're gonna be
excreted that way forget about it or you
know like William Faulkner the great
novelist said and one of the famous
essay in the 50s you're probably right
but go slow well you know obviously he
had never heard of Patrick Henry give me
he'll give me freedom will give me death
well my parents will give me freedom
would give me death they were they were
not ever apologetic they fought to the
bitter end and and so I grew up seeing
all of that and and it certainly hadn't
had an impact on on who I became in the
long run but they were they were too now
we many 60 years later 50 years later
America is a different place America is
not virulent ly racist racism is no long
no longer stops the dreams and hopes of
any black person in American life you
can do anything you want you can be the
president you can be a CEO you can be a
dishwasher you can be anything you
choose to be in America today does that
mean that every white person is gonna
love you I don't know and don't care
what's important is that you have that
opportunity
the opportunity is is what it's all
about so the civil rights movement today
is is very different than back then
they're not fighting against a real
racism a real enemy that that is going
to stunt their lives with bigotry
they're fighting now basically for the
rewards for all of for they're
manipulating white guilts they're
they're using the story of black
victimization to manipulate the larger
society into entitlements and our we
have a generation of black leaders who
do nothing but shakedown major American
corporations this is the this is not the
civil rights movement of my parents it's
not the one I grew up in it's a very
different what's your connection to
Stanford University and the Hoover
Institution I am a senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford
University which has always been very
happy about it's a great great
institution great people they're a great
environment and colleagues it's it's
meant everything to me and to my work
and has facilitated that so I'm
I'm a fan this is what your 10th 15th
book no it's not that many but it's a
and there's some that we're kind of here
and there but it's it's a problem it's
probably the fifth book that wouldn't
have written on racial matters Shelby
Steele has been our guest on book TV
shame how America's past sins have
polarized our country dr. Steele one
final question I know you're here at
Freedom Fest yeah there's a specific
reason you're here yes there is I have a
son
Shelby Eli Steele who was a young
documentary filmmaker and he has a film
the new film out that he's showing here
it's called I am : how Jack became black
and it's a look at identity politics
jack is his son and he tells the story
of taking him to school the first day
and I'm saying he had to identify his
primary race or he couldn't go to school
here in the United States of America
well that's how the film opens and
and it's explorers explores all of that
that controversy I think shows the the
essential corruption of identity
politics why it doesn't work why it
hurts the people it wants to help thank
you for your time
I'm here to see that cheer him on here's
a look at two books Vermont senator
Patrick Leahy is reading this summer
anthony doors Pulitzer Prize winning
novel alt of light we cannot see telling
the story of two children struggling to
survive in France during World War two
and Minnesota senator Al Franken's giant
of the Senate recalling his path from
Santa risk to politician book TV wants
to know what you're reading
send us your summer reading list via
Twitter at book TV or Instagram at book
underscore TV or post it to our Facebook
page facebook.com slash book TV book TV
on c-span - television for serious
readers next on book TV Roxane gay
discusses her body and its impact on her
life in her memoir hunger this program
contains language that some may find
offensive
[Applause]
[Applause]
good evening Roxane gay is the New York
Times bestselling author of bad feminist
and untamed state difficult women IET
and Marvel's world of Wakanda she is a
contributing opinion writer to the New
York Times and has also written for Time
McSweeney's the Nation Salaam and more
her fiction has been selected for the
best American short stories of 2012 and
the best American mystery stories of
2014
among other anthologies in her new book
Hunger Roxane delivers a searing lianas
memoir of food weight self-image and
learning how to feed your hunger while
taking care of yourself
joining Roxane on stage this evening is
Tech Lady Mafia co-founder and co-host
of the call your girlfriend podcast
Amina so without further ado please join
me in welcoming Amina so and tonight's
featured author Roxane gay
[Applause]
[Music]
you're supposed to do so we're taking a
selfie my sister's gonna be so jealous
hello thanks so much for joining us
today I'm so excited to talk to you this
book is this book is amazing it's you
know you know I mean you're you're like
Kanye to me only shoot three-pointers so
I knew I wasn't gonna be disappointed it
was perfect
fire-making of three-pointers there's a
basketball game tonight sorry trust but
I was I was so struck by so many things
when when I read the book I had to stop
many times because it was it was very
emotional it was really raw and I was so
I was just reminded of how just generous
you are as a person somebody who is not
afraid to say the thing that we we are
all thinking or we should be thinking
and helps us be a little more brave and
yeah can you kind of talk to us about
what what you know like what was hard
about writing this for you everything oh
you went sure you know it was a
difficult book to write I sold this book
and just before bad feminist came out
actually and I was thinking about what I
wanted my next nonfiction project to be
and I thought the book I want to write
least is a book about fatness and then I
realized it's the book I should probably
write the most and my dad always tells
me do something no one else is doing if
you want to achieve success and a lot of
people write about fatness from the
perspective of having already figured
out their body and have lost a lot of
weight and so you see a woman on the
cover of her book standing in half of
her formerly fat pants and she's like I
did it
and and I just thought I can't write
that book yet and I want to write that
book so why don't I tell the story of my
body today without apology
I'm just explanation this is my fat body
and this is what it is like to be in
this world in this body yeah I mean I
think one of the things that I really
enjoy too that you did in the book is
that there's you know for as many new
perspectives as we hear about like
bodies and about abuse and about rape
culture I still think that there is a
singular narrative of how you are
supposed to react to when like hard
things happen to you and I think that
you you were really able to like shift
that conversation and change the
conversation from you know like in
saying yes there's such a thing as
health at every size but here's where I
am right there is such a thing as
whatever the fad beauty like empowerment
complexes online but here's where I am
at and also the conversation around like
you know choosing to call yourself a
victim or a survivor and I think you
know it was so important that that you
did that what kind like what reactions
are you hearing to that well the
nobody's read the book yet well a few
people have read the book yet but it
comes out tomorrow and so I haven't
gotten many reactions a lot of people
have made assumptions based on what they
think the book is going to be about and
they think that it's a book about self
loathing and so on and I and that's not
what this book is about it's a book
about like what happens when you are
beyond Lane Bryant and because we
oftentimes when people talk about body
positivity and fat positivity they can
still go to the mall and buy an outfit
but what happens when you're bigger than
that and what happens when you find
yourself no longer able to shop in a
store for clothing and you know when the
world simply does not accommodate you
it's a story we don't hear unless you
are watching TLC and one of their
horrific exploitative shows like my
600-pound life where then the fat body
becomes a spectacle and this idea of
being shamed and we have this doctor who
I'm sure is well intended but puts
people on a 1200 calorie a day diet even
though at the beginning of the show they
say that the weight loss surgery has a 5
and success rate and I think that lets
us know how pervasive fat called fat
phobia is that people are like oh I have
a 95% chance of failing at this but I'm
going to mutilate my body anyway and I
just wanted to talk about all that and I
wanted to say I believe in fat
positivity and health at every size but
I'm also not thrilled to be this
particular size I actually met the
health at every size founder last week
and she weighs about 90 pounds she's a
medical doctor and so I love that she's
taking up this cause because people will
listen to her far more than they'll ever
listen to anyone else because of her
thinness and she even said that to me
but I just thought wow wow okay she's
super thin she will never know what it's
like to live in this body but sure happy
and healthy at every size and so I yeah
I'm all for it but I'm also just me and
trying to be as realistic as I can
another thing I you know I really liked
about the book is how it confronted with
it confronted me with my own kind of my
own history with weight and where I you
know like where I think I am I I think
I've been big probably since I was in
the sixth grade never really thought
about it too much
I like also went through sexual trauma
but I had never connected those dots in
the way that you you lay bare like so so
much but I you know I was so I just
realized how much of this conversation
about wait to just centers around like
fat people be miserable all the time
which is like not necessarily true for
some of us like some of us have athletic
sex some of us like it's true your
family's here
[Laughter]
I'm sorry mom and dad cover your ears
this is not for you we'll get to the
portion that's for later you know but
where where you're able to talk about
all of these things and also you know
like realize that the conversation
around being fat doesn't have to send
her around Fitness dolphins I think it's
so important for people to realize that
you can be fat and live a full life you
have we have relationships we have
families we have jobs sometimes we're
really good at those jobs and people
love to tell us it doesn't matter what
you achieve as long as you're fat your
achievements don't count for anything
and I definitely wanted to write against
that narrative I hear it constantly
certainly because I live in the world
but I also know that I live a full life
and then this is not to be all to end
all and it is not you know the ruling
factor and neither is misery but people
want us to be miserable they want us to
punish ourselves because they feel like
fat is a problem that needs to be solved
and that we should be constantly
apologizing for our bodies and it's not
about them it's very odd I mean when I
was reading your book in the subway a
man came up to me to give me a diet
advice which I thought was hilarious
I get so much nutritional advice I was
in Chicago recently doing an event and a
man came up to me and gave me his name
and number but not in the good way
he was like I'm a nutritionist like what
the [ __ ] and last night the Washington
Post did this feature on me over the
weekend and don't read the comments I
just don't and a guy emailed me last
night and said I don't know if you know
this but exercise is really required to
lose weight and I just thought you know
you're like I'm a tenure forward never
learned that I have a PhD but you're
right
you're right I have a personal trainer
but I don't know anything here thank you
thank you
he was like just walk two or three times
a week and I could tell that this man
was being really kind in like earnest
and I so I haven't written him back
because my first response was not kind
and nor was but it was artists like
earnest we go [ __ ] yourself
sorry Parker it's very very frustrating
I mean but is it kind of though I think
that you know one of the things that
you're able to talk about so well too is
how when when your body is not the norm
whatever society has decided the normans
it's people think it's okay to comment
about it they do okay to shove you they
think it's okay they talk to you about
what your varnish sounds like absolutely
they think that they can treat you like
a garbage cans that's all you are
I mean I can't tell you the number of
times I get shoved in public when people
don't even apologize as if the fatness
is it makes you immune from pain like a
force field no I thought so but it
doesn't work that way but it the body
does become part of the public
conversation and it becomes public
property and that's extremely
frustrating because people read like one
magazine article in people and think
that they are some suddenly an expert
and everybody is a doctor everybody is a
doctor not a day goes by when people
don't give me statistics that I know
already because I live in the world and
I've read a book it's yeah it's
maddening I want to shake all of those
people for you you know it's not
kindness but I think they perceive it as
kindness I think that they think they're
doing you a favor and like presenting
you with some information that you've
somehow never seen it Oprah commercial
or opened a book or seen a television
show where diet culture is consistently
being thrown at us like they think that
somehow we've blocked it all out
which like teach me I love to learn that
it's not crazy you know another one of
the things I think that you do so so
well is just is you know open up this
conversation around shame that people
have whether it's around whether it's
around the salt or it's around like how
you feel about your body but that's what
I felt reading it where I was like
slowly the shame is just lifting little
by little limits by having these kinds
of conversations like what was you know
what were you kind of trying to get to
really in talking about this you know I
didn't have an end goal when I started
writing the book I just knew I wanted to
write about fatness and I wanted to sort
of fatness is this thing where people
don't really want to talk about it and
they know you're fat but they whisper
around it or they have the audacity to
say oh girl you're not fat no I think I
am and they try to like minimize your
reality or again they just project a
narrative onto your body that is full of
assumptions and so I just wanted to to
end that and say you know this is not
the truth
as I wrote the book I found myself
taking a really hard look at myself and
the choices that I've made over the
years and then how once I was as fixed
as I'm ever going to be I just was
comfortable in a certain way of being
and it was all I knew and so it's all I
did and so that was really useful and
also just learning that I don't have to
apologize for my body which is a work in
progress but writing the book certainly
got me to at least recognize that and be
able to articulate that I love that I
think too you know when one thing that's
like fairly apparent about this kind of
conversation is that yes you're writing
about fatness and the politics of
fatness but what it really does is open
up a larger conversation
around accessibility and how we treat
people with different kind of bodies
like I know that you are somebody who is
really conscious about when you go on
book tour like making sure that there's
accessible seating for everyone that you
know that you can accommodate different
kind of bodies and that is you know
unfortunately like that's not a thing
that a lot of people think about they
don't like one of my event in Ann Arbor
is in an auditorium which means it's
gonna be tiny seats with rigid arms and
so I asked the venue they need to have
seats available with no arms for people
who cannot fit in those seats and nobody
thinks about that because people
generally assume that we all fit in the
world the way you do and you the norm is
treated as thin and anybody beyond that
shouldn't leave the house and so I do
think accessibility is important and for
this tour I ask that every venue have
accessible seating for everyone and for
different kinds of bodies we'll see how
it goes
yeah I mean you know it's kind of crazy
that we all assume that the norm is this
like thin body because we like we see
the statistics right it's like the the
fashion industry doesn't cater to the
real bodies of women we know how much
like our body sizes have change or
whatever but there is such a resistance
to just accepting the reality of where
you know whatever the average American
woman's body is and then extrapolating
that to larger things like now what do
you think it's really going to change
it's going really going to take to
change that conversation I don't know
but it's gonna take probably as with all
things the financial imperative enough
people are going to have to have the
economic power to demand that we design
seats that are wider than 17 inches
which is the average width of a chair
and I don't know if that's ever going to
happen because all too often designers
whether it's furniture designers or
clothing designers you know they're like
no I want to design for a size two
because otherwise I can't feel artistic
and creative which lets you know how bad
most designers are
I mean if you can't imagine your way out
of the sighs - what are you doing I
don't know what it's going to take I
think this is one of the final frontiers
of discrimination and I don't I don't
know what it's gonna take
well if you don't know how are we gonna
know you know when I was reading - I
just I found myself being really like
protective of you where it was like oh
my gosh I know what she's trying to say
this is so smart it's amazing but so
many people are not going to get it it
was like absolutely going to fly over
their heads
oh yeah and seeing some of the you know
like some of the coverage you know of
your piece are cut other ways that
people have engaged you like you tweeted
about something today asking you to
describe your body for example very you
know like very offensive where it's like
you've engaged with this material and
he's like like that how are you enjoying
with yeah it's really interesting when
people read the book and like still
learn nothing from it
this I did I did a radio interview this
morning with a woman I've actually
interviewed with at least twice before
and she said and she used NPR voice as
if she was trying to like really connect
with me on my level
so she was like an white lady and so she
was like so describe your body to me I
was like a nice damn bird I said I'm
tall because I knew what she was trying
to get me to do and she was expecting me
to like just enter this this fugue of
self-loathing and just be like my body's
this huge hulking mass but you know
that's not how I think of myself because
I do need to get through the day and
then later in the interview she came
back and she said so describe your body
to me and I lost my [ __ ] and I just said
seriously and she was like yes and I was
like and then I just no ma'am
I hope they air it I hope they air I had
a witness my publicist was there and she
was like yes it's exactly as bad as you
think it people don't know how to talk
about it and every single review so far
I write in the book what my highest
weight was and I wrote it just to give
people context because people are
actually really bad about guessing
numbers of what weight looks like people
think that every woman weighs 140 pounds
or 110 pounds and she's like now I'm
rocking to 10 and every single review
has mentioned it every single one and
I'm just like like really
obsession with the thinness and the and
you know and people still read weight
loss memoirs to find they're like it's
almost dangerous to write about your you
know like your weight or what it is that
you're trying to do because people
instead of like getting a they'll use it
as a manual for like okay yes yeah this
is how I don't become her which he'd be
so lucky
it's very frustrating and you know
people like want answers or they want it
to be a cautionary tale like how do like
what what is the number where I need to
start panicking and just do over it's
really interesting the coverage has been
well intended but interesting I'm like
you should start panicking when you're
not in the Klan writer probably yeah I
mean it's that's like really interesting
I love to you know that you say in like
in the intro to the book you talk about
how it's specifically a memoir about
your body and like where you were at
right now and I think that you know the
the form itself like challenges that let
you know like on some level it is a
traditional memoir it's like we get to
learn about your childhood your family
the college years but the way that it's
written is you know I think that the
focus on the the thematic focus on the
body is like very interesting yeah
definitely I never wanted to write a
memoir and I always told myself okay
I'll write a memoir when my parents died
there's nothing in my life that they
don't already know or that they can't
know don't read the book so I just
thought okay if I have a focus it'll be
easier and so I was very deliberate
about making sure that it stayed focused
on my body because that's what the book
is about and so that's how I as I got
deeper into the book whenever I felt
lost I just thought okay how does
whatever it is that you're talking about
in this moment relate to your body and
that helped me stay on course yeah you
know another thing about you for if you
don't follow Roxanne on social media
platform you're a fool because that's
where you get like a lot of good stuff
for free you know I like like we like in
my friend group we always joke about
like how good you are at the internet
it's like no no like dastardly good yes
and you know there are parts of reading
this book where there's like this whole
arc that I didn't know about how you
know like you you spent so much time
online talking to strangers in Internet
chat room
and you know like being a lurker and
being a contributor and I thought that
there was there was some you know
obviously like that came from a place of
pain but to see the the full realization
of that and I think that it goes back
again to how just generous you are with
sharing your ideas and sharing your life
and you know and letting people in on
the level that they can relate to which
I've always accused of not doing in my
actual life it's so funny but yeah I've
been online probably since 1996 back in
the day I went to college and my parents
gave me a macintosh LC - and back then
we would use a 2400 baud modem to get
online and tie up the phone line and
when I would go home I would actually
take this big computer in a box like
laptops did not exist and I would tie up
the phone for 16 hours at a time
and I would just talk because I was so
shy and I was so just afraid of the
world but I had a very vivid imagination
and a very large desire to like be out
in the world and being on the Internet
allowed that and so I would go on
message boards back in the day and just
talk to strange people and back then
believe it or not the Internet was
fairly safe it wasn't what it is today
like you could talk to a 40 year old
died and not get murdered as an 18 year
old girl which is not necessarily the
case anymore also I think I was very
lucky but I just loved I'm a writer
I worked best with writing and not
having to do face to face interactions
and so it just was great to have this a
medium and so now I'm like you're seeing
something I've been doing since 96 yeah
I should hope I'm good at Twitter at
this point
oh I mean I you know our culture is so
obsessed with like boon Durkins it's
always like a 30 under 35 tights under
fiver I gotta tell you I I shed a tear
when I turned 40 because I didn't ever
make the New Yorkers 40 under 40 list or
whatever the 20 under 40 oh I was
heartbroken stretch it to 42 under 42 oh
yeah but you know I think that your but
your story though is like so much more
beautiful than that right it's like
somebody it's like part of your success
one is that you've been doing it forever
you know it's just like okay like I know
what I'm actually doing
and I'm seasoned and I'm a pro but I
think that it's also to me at least like
it was really heartening to be like okay
you can be you can toil at something for
a long time and do it and when when
success comes and when your opportunity
comes you're ready because you've you
know like there's no impostor syndrome
no well there is tons of impostor
syndrome but I know that meritocracy
doesn't exist and I but I always told
myself cream rises to the top that's how
I sort of got through the many many
years of obscurity and not being very
good and I just got better and I got
better and you know I was fortunate
enough to be raised with the kinds of
advantages that put me in the position
to succeed like it's not an accident
success is rarely an accident and I very
much acknowledge that at all times but
I've put in the work and so often times
people are like overnight sensation and
I'm like
now if I'm an overnight sensation it's
the longest overnight in the history it
took some time can we talk about your
family I'm so way they came deep I have
a lot of relatives and patients real
deep I see but you know I think that
there is I don't know for me at least
like also as an immigrant like hearing a
you know how close you all are and how
just like your parents have really been
there at like crucial moments even when
you didn't have that kind of the
vocabulary and the courage to talk to
them about it it's something that is
it's really it's great yeah because a
lot of times you know we hear mostly
about the tensions in immigrant families
oh yeah those were there but I mean I
was like 19 20 whenever but my brothers
and I went through those little issues
it was always like in our early tea late
teens or early 20s when you shouldn't
talk to children at all no there's
nothing good happening there no I don't
have the we didn't have those tensions
for whatever reason bless you it's just
I was lucky I had parents who were
willing to parent even when I did not
want to be parented Haitian parents
parent forever trust me they bossed me
around today and give me like advice and
like what are you doing
did you have dinner yet I got this
I live on my own in everything but it's
a blessing I didn't my American friends
are oftentimes surprised of like your
parents call you how often and I'm like
every day I promise you it's just is
what it is and I think that oftentimes
in in marginalized cultures and in a
country like Haiti the asset you have is
people and family because lord knows
everything else is working against you
so I think that's one of the many
reasons you know we have a very close
family that's great I'm gonna start
telling people I'm on that I'm on the
adoption like short yeah I think you're
in the top five top five and maybe top
two there's a little bit of a waiting
list but so that's so great and you
talked about also earlier how you had to
delay writing some of the book because
it was just like really like you know
like we talked about how hard it was
yeah what was the you know like how
hashtag blessed are you that you can you
know take your time writing a book and
the relationship that you have with with
the team that is publishing and yeah and
all of that I'm very lucky because I was
just like I would just keep making up
these deadlines every single time they
were like okay and I was like you know
I'm lying this time
I got a fifth deadline I could tell the
day knew I was lying but they just let
me lie it was really really quite sweet
um yeah I put up I just really dragged
my feet on writing the book because it
was so difficult to be so open and I was
dreading whatever is going to happen in
the next two weeks very very much
and so I'm gonna actually ignore as much
of it as I can and it was just I didn't
want to like face it or face myself and
find
I just decided do you really want to pay
back the advance like Oh like that's a
lot of money that's a joke I just it was
just like Roxanne suck it up you said
you were gonna write the book just write
the goddamn book and so I did finally
but I was really lucky to be supported
by an editor and a publisher and an
agent and my agent in particular Maria
who never once nagged me never and
through in like two years of delays
never gave me any pressure books take
good books take time and so I was given
that time I love and I'm so glad that
you wrote it a tune for now ask me again
tomorrow night and how I feel